اريد ان اسمع تعليقك عن هذا الحديث الرسمي
الان من قبل رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو
بضروره السيطره على محور فيلادلفيا من قبل
اسرائيل ده حديث سياسي الحديث الرسمي لما
يتقدم لطلب لمصر
بتعديل الملحق الامني الخاص باتفاقيه
السلام المصريه الاسرائيليه اللي هي في
البند الرابع بتشيل الملحق الامني واللي
اتفاقيه فك الارتباط منش عنها من ممر فض
فيلادلفيا صلاح الدين ومعبر رفح البري
وتشكيل قوات الحرس الحدود لخدمه هذا يعني
تامين هذه الحدود من الجانب المصري لابد
من تعديلها وتعديلها يتم عن طريق اللجنه
العسكريه المصريه العليا ومجرد اقرارها
ودخولها حز التنفيذ تعتبر جزء من
الاتفاقيه السلام افايه السلام كانت مصريه
اسرائيليه برعايه امريكيه ف كون ان هو
يعني يقوم بهذا الفعل من طرف واحد يعتبر
خالف بنود الاتفاقيه
وبالمناسبه الجانب الاسرائيلي مش حر حتى
في حدوده خارج قطاع غزه هناك المنطقه دال
يعني دائما الحديث عن المنطقه يعني وب وجي
اللي هي من قناه سويس وحتى الحدود لكن
هناك المنطقه د حتى جنوب كرم ابو سالم في
11 كيلو الجانب الاسرائيلي مسؤول عن اعلام
مصر باي نشاط عسكري مخالف في تلك المنطقه
فيعني هذا الحديث ربما يكون للاستهلاك
المحلي للداخل الاسرائيلي طيب ربما جاء
ردا على سؤال احراجه لكن الدول لا تتفاعل
عن طريق التصريحات الصحفيه هناك قنوات
دبلوماسيه تعمل هناك قنوات عسكريه تعمل
هناك قنوات مخابراتيه تعمل قدرت بان ما
صرح بنتنياهو بانه او تقدير او ذا بعد
سياسي هل معنى ذك انك تستبعد ان تقوم
اسرائيل بالخطوات التي ذكرت حتى تسيطر على
هذا المحور محور فيلادلفيا
احنا في اليوم الين لحرب فالحديث اللي
بيحصل سواء من عسكريين زي بني جانز او
سياسيين مش في الحكم مش في الحكم او داخل
ارخه الحكم هو حديث يعني لا يرقى المستوى
الرسمي المنضبط لان بعد خ 80 يوم هل
ادركوا الان ان هناك تهديدات تاتي عبر
الحدود المصريه هم يعلموا تماما ان مصر
احكمت السيطره على الحدود وعلى الانفاق
قبل حرب غزه بسنوات كان بغرض تامين
الانفاق وحركه الانفاق اللي مصر عانت منها
كتير الحقيقه فبالتالي الحديث اليوم هو
هروب من مواجهه ما يحدث شمال من تلك
المنطقه ما يحدث في خانيونس ما يحدث في
محافظه الوسط في في غزه محافظه الشمال في
الشجاعيه في الزيتون ا تعثر العمليات
الخسائر الكبيره بدا الجانب الاسرائيلي
يبحث عن شماعه ف فجاه يعني تفق ذهنهم على
فكره ان هناك امدادات تاتي من من من رفع
بالاضافه لان القرار احتلال الممر اولا
بيصطبح ل للمعاهده واتفاقيه فك الارتباط
ومع الجانب الامريكي اللي بيطلب التخفيف
وتخفي وخفض التصعيد واللي بيعتبر ان
محافظه رفح محافظه امنه ف قضيه احتلال
الممر ربما تكون هي مجرد
يعني حجه لا ارى لها يعني اي معنى
والانقسام ما بين المؤسسه العسكريه ممثله
في رئيس الاركان طيب اراك تعتمد م واضحه
العميد سمير تعتمد مصطلح احتلال الممر او
احتلال المحور
ماذا عن هذا المصطلح في حال ما اقدمت
اسرائيل على هذه
الخطوه اقولك خلينا بس هو في في العربي
الاثنين احتلال ده مش ري اكيوبيشن بيكوز
اوردي اكباد لاند يعني يعني ده ما يعتبرش
احتلال الاراضي اصلا تقع ضمن اراضي 67
يعني هي اراضي محتله ده يعتبر ريدي بلمنت
يعني ما يعتبرش يعني كلمه احتلال في
العربي واحد لكن هو ريدي بلمنت مش مش فكره
ان هو يعني مش ما كانتش ارض محرره وهو راح
يحتلها هي زيها زي اراضي غزه بل حتى لما
كان قبل فك الارتباط كان متواجد في
فيلادلفيا صلاح الدين يعني حتى لما كانوا
اهل غزه تحت الاحتلال كانت قواته بتفصل ما
بين الور الفلسطيني في غزه والسور المصري
فدا ماقدرش اقول عليه يعني لكن هو في
العربي الاثنين ان هو احتلال لكن انا اللي
بيربطني هو اولا قرار عسكري وترتيبات
عسكريه ولابد طبعا احنا عندنا في
مصر يعني القائد السياسي هو القائد
العسكري رئيس الجمهوريه هو القائد الاعلى
القوات المسلحه اذا اللجنه خدت قرار
بتعرضه على القائد الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
رئيس الجمهوريه الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي
على الجانب الاخر بتجتمع اللجنه العسكريه
وتعرض على من يتولى منصب القائد الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه والقرار لا يعرض على
البرلمان ما يتعلق بالملحق الامني يعني اي
تعديل في الملحق الامني لا يحتاج لموافقه
الحكومه في الطرفين او البرلمان في
الطرفين مجرد ما اللجنه تصدق وتتفق وترفع
للقائد الاعلى او من يقوم بدوره يعني
دلوقتي في الور كابينت هل هو ده القائد
الاعلى ولا نتنياهو هو القائد الا يعني من
يشغل هذا المنصب لكن في الاخير هي اجراءات
عذرا على المقاطعه ما قاله نتنياهو هذا
اليوم ليس لاول مره قبل ايام ايضا جرى
تسريب والحديث عن السيطره على محور
فيلادلفيا
الا يدلل بان هناك ربما جديه اسرائيليه في
القيام بهذه الخطوه واذا ماحال م قامت
بهذه الخطوه ما المتوقع من رد الفعل
المصري حيال هذه
الخطوه تمام هو
الكلام على احتلال ممر في لاديل في صلاح
الدين من وجهه نظر عسكريه بحته انه في حال
ان هو هيقوم بعمليات
بريه ضد محافظه رفع ضلع فلادلفيا صلاح
الدين هو الضلع الجنوبي
فبالتالي المناطق ومع اتساع القطاع في
مناطق الجنوب بيحتاج ان هو يحاصر من
الجنوب ويقوم بعمليات من الجنوب بالاضافه
للعمليات اللي تاتي من الشمال من محافظه
قن يونس او من الشرق من محور سوف ده
الكلام ده كلام عسكري لكن سينشا عنه وضع
قانوني لابد من نسال سؤال لما هيقوم ده
هيقوم منفردا يعني من طرف واحد دون تنسيق
يكون خالف معاهده السلام المصريه
الاسرائيليه الملحق الامني يعني مخالفه
مخالفه الاتفاقيه كلها يتساوى مع لو ان
مصر قامت بعبور قوات للقناه غير مخطط ليها
في المعاهده او غير منصوص على عددها في
المعاهده او مخالفه او يعني تدفع الجيش
الثاني والثالث الى المنطقه ج مثلا
فبالتالي ا ما اعتقدش انه يقدر يقوم
بالموضوع ده منفردا طيب لما يعرضوا بشكل
رسمي القرار في هذا القرار ل للقياده
العسكريه بتنسيق
مع او بتصديق السيد القائد الاعلى للقوات
المسلحه رئيس الجمهوريه بتسلسل القيادي
طبعا بمرو باللجنه رئيس اركان حرب القوات
المسلحه المصريه القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه فاجرات دي ليس اجراءات سريه جميع
التعديلات طبعا حصل تعديلات على اتفاقيه
على الملحق الامني
بتشكيل فوق حرس حدود بتعديلات على قوات
حرس الحدود بدخول قوات اضافيه مؤقتا للحرب
على الارهاب ودي تمت عن طريق اللجنه
وبتنسيق ما بين الطرفين
وبموافقته المصري وموافقه الجانب
الاسرائيلي يعني دي السوابق اللي حصلت
فبالتالي ما اعتقدش ان هو هيلجا من طرف
واحد واعتقد الجانب المصري لابد ان هو
يناقشه من شقين الشق العسكري ما الدافع من
ذلك والشق السياسي تاثير هذا على الهدن
وعلى يعني خفض التصعيد والدخول في وقف
اطلاق ن